all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here in studio just swagged out my
number one question like we talked about
last time is global liquidity if Global
liquidity increases asset prices go up
if it drains asset prices go down I'm a
simple simple man which direction are we
headed right now uh so let's uh let's
take a trip down memory lane and talk
about where we've been with global
liquidity because I think that really
sets the stage for kind of the near term
and medium term outlooks for the for
this particular variable and there's a
lot of variables by the way that drive
asset markets this for the past let's
call it two or three years has been the
primary driver so obviously it's a big
deal so if you go back into so let's
just take a step back and what the hell
is global liquidity right we talk about
liquidity all the time as investors but
we don't really have a you know real
true academic consensus on what the
concept of global liquidity is so uh in
the context of uh trying to understand
this and understanding this for my
quantitative economics background you
know I think there's a few statistics
that we like to focus on that give you a
general sense of kind of where this kind
of squishy concept of Global liquidity
are number one you look at the
aggregated central bank balance sheet
you know particularly across the major
uh you know kind of G20 economies U.S
you know the ECB the fed the bank of
England pboc the the bank of Japan Swiss
National Bank et cetera these kind of at
least if you those six uh central banks
they account for more than 90 of the
total central bank balance sheets so if
you're going to spend any time
aggregating this stuff definitely start
there and focus on there uh the number
two metric uh we would talk about is
what I would consider to be private
sector liquidity so that's public sector
liquidity liquidity coming from central
banks there's private sector liquidity
liquidity that comes from commercial
Banks and the best way to track that
it's not necessarily a direct proxy but
the best way to track that is through uh
M1 money supply narrow money supply on
their money supply includes the monetary
base but was primarily driven by Bank
deposits demand deposits on it and Banks
and so if you look at both of those
metrics those are other metrics as well
like World FX reserves is less relevant
but those kinds of other things do
matter when you go back and you look at
the Central Bank Global Center balance
sheet at right around 30 trillion it had
increased a couple trillion off the lows
of late 2022 and so that you know part
of what we've seen in this kind of
year-to-date Robin Bitcoin kind of the
bottoming in the s p type exposures risk
assets since you know kind of October of
last year has really been a function of
that uptick well the one thing I would
call out on that is that we've actually
reversed negatively in recent months in
fact uh kind of peaked out in late
January early February at the previous
year to date high in the s p and we have
yet to kind of recover on that level if
you look at a global narrow money supply
it's actually continuing to Trend lower
if you if you look at it on a year over
year basis uh both returning lower World
nearing money supplies uh very narrow
modestly uh negative at minus 0.3
percent domestic narrow money supply
because of the deposit outflow that
we're seeing primarily from Regional
Banks but it's not just Regional Banks
it's large commercial Banks as well here
in the US that's down about six percent
on a year-over-year basis and that's
about as sharp as the contractions
you're ever going to see and so
the Improvement in global liquidity that
was primarily driven by this inflection
central bank balance sheets primarily
driven by the bank of Japan defending
its yield curve control policy and the
pboc kind of trying to give you know the
the Chinese economy a little push when
it was coming out of zero covert a few
months ago that stuff's kind of reversed
it's kind of peaked out and topped out
and we are now starting to see global
liquidity drain on a trailing
three-month basis kind of you know the
data through March data through April so
there was a lot of debate about uh let's
say the ECB and they were bucking the
trend of the feds the Fed was saying one
thing and the ECB was kind of fighting
and say ah we're not going to do that
they eventually capitulated and now
they're pretty much moving at least
directionally in lockstep uh in terms of
uh you know creating tighter Financial
conditions now we saw out of Asia uh
that wasn't the case we actually did as
you mentioned uh earlier this year see
them increasing the liquidity in the
market who's in charge does the fed the
lead kind of the global Central Bank you
know strategy session if you will does
uh China or the boj or somebody else
like how do we think about like is there
one Central Bank to look at and what
they say will basically then Ripple
through the rest of the central banks or
or each one of these central banks
actually making individual decisions for
themselves uh it's a little bit of both
so uh no one's in charge right like
let's let's be honest here right the
debt you know the FED is primarily
partially in control of the dollar
obviously with alongside the U.S
treasury Department and so you could say
that given that we are on a global
dollar Reserve System and probably will
be for extended period of time the FED
is technically in charge but the reality
is a none of these central banks is
actually in charge of global liquidity
they all contribute individually um you
know to varying degrees and at various
points in the cycle based on their own
economic drivers you know why would a
central bank either add or subtract
liquidity from its own economy you can
obviously infer you know the reasons for
that growth being above or below Trend
inflation being meaningfully above or
bleeding through below Trend Etc you
know unemployment situation being uh
pretty adverse and what we're seeing
right now particularly with respect to
the European economy particularly with
respect to the Chinese economy these
economies are actually improving you
know pretty markedly in recent months
and so the probability that we need to
see any sort of liquidity provision out
of these localities is actually
diminishing at the margins um in fact
the ECB balance sheet continues to be in
pretty uh meaningful contraction it was
the pboc's balance sheet on the bank of
Japan's balance sheet that really
contributed to that meaningful uptick in
global liquidity I want to say on a
trolling three-month basis it peaked in
January at about 1.4 trillion dollars
but on in aggregate was somewhere around
plus two trillion dollars off the lows
of last year and so you know you can a
lot of folks want to make it easy you
know again so much of investing is like
people trying to find shortcuts and cut
corners and and I just want to remind
viewers is you know there are people
spending billions of dollars on research
and trading and all this stuff it's not
easy I wouldn't try to cut corners but
in the context of This Global liquidity
discussion I think you can to some
degree you know kind of focus on these
primary large major central banks these
primary large major economies because
they're that's going to get you to at
least 90 95 percent of the total total
outcome so we've seen to the start of
2023 Bitcoin was the best performing
asset in q1 there's about 70 or so and
we saw a lot of assets going up right it
wasn't just a Bitcoin or a
cryptocurrency thing should there be a
belief that similar to what we saw
coming out of 2020 into 2021 like when
all asset prices rise Bitcoin is just
kind of uh uh you know an asset price on
steroids and it's going to go up more
and then if you go through the long tail
of all the crypto assets like they'll
have higher and higher price
appreciation or is there something
different in the way that you analyze
Bitcoin versus maybe some of the
traditional assets I would say since the
March Regional banking Panic here in the
US there has certainly become a greater
store of value bid in the Bitcoin asset
class than I think had added previously
before you know I don't know that we can
say what percentage of Bitcoins price
change price fluctuations are being
driven by store value versus risk
appetite Global liquidity et cetera but
I certainly think that whatever that pie
chart look like in terms of global
liquidity Global risk appetite you know
Global or you know sort of store value I
think this the pie slice associated with
the shore value has certainly increased
um in recent months and part of the
reason we're seeing that is because you
know we have various metrics that kind
of track whether or not you know hey you
know is liquidity improving is you know
risk appetite improving vis-a-vis sector
and style Factor dispersion in the
equity Market we can certainly look at
the bond market whether it be yield
curves or forward spreads or Etc to give
us an idea okay it's you know growth
expectations Rising are people wanting
to take more risk and want to speculate
more and the reality is we've not seen
all those traditional drivers of the
Bitcoin price you know really improve in
fact I would argue we've seen them
actually deteriorate in recent months um
obviously the simple negative inflection
Global liquidity from kind of the
January February highs of that of those
time Series has actually gotten worse
we've seen you know degradation and
fixed income curves and money market
curves we've just really nasty record
inversion in the one month Bill minus
the three month T bill is signaling a
lot of stress in the collateral system
in the repo system and Report market so
I would argue Global risk appetite has
not really improved either as alongside
Global liquidity Global liquidity is
down risk appetite at best is flat but
we've seen the Bitcoin price rally
pretty sharply off the marsh lows of of
the March lows of 2023. and in our
opinion I think that's got to be some
deposit flow instead of saying hey just
give me an Uncle Sam piece of paper a
money market t-bill fund let me put some
of this in a digital asset like Bitcoin
as a longer term store value and it's no
surprise to me that this is happening
given the deposit situation at Silicon
Valley Bank right Signature Bank these
are institutions these are companies and
people and individuals and Founders who
believe in these assets from a longer
term perspective so I think they came to
a fork on the road and said well if my
depository institution's going bus where
do I put all this money and put some of
any t-bills but I can also put some of
it in something like Bitcoin earlier we
were talking about Bitcoin and the
having that's about a year away or so
and you had mentioned some things and
the analysis that you've done in terms
of bitcoin's price and the volatility
going into the having talk a little bit
about that yeah so so one thing that's
kind of really
made you know so you we talked about
this a couple weeks ago and I was last
on the program which is you know we have
this concept of the face true credit
cycle downturn ahead of us and and for
those of you who I don't want to rehash
it for too much but the reality is when
you go into a recession particularly in
the US economy because we are the
world's dominant economy dominant asset
markets dominant Reserve currency
typically what happens you have this
sort of nasty blood and credit spreads
you have this really nasty sort of
repricing and sector and style factors
version the equity markets and of course
you have a crash in the equity markets
themselves and risk assets tend to
correlate uh with that with that outcome
so that's an outcome that we still see
ahead of us you know more than likely
commencing in the second half of this
year probably by late Q3 given the
timing with which we anticipate a
recession to develop in the US economy
we have a bunch of different models on
on kind of timing where we are in the
business cycle uh here in the US and and
the kind of the modal outcome of that
those models suggests Q4 is probably the
the highest probability starting point
for recession so we were assuming that
you know sometime in Q3 and Q4 we're
going to be in the middle of pricing or
at the beginning of pricing and face to
credit cycle downturn one thing that
sort of has me with respect to bitcoin
specifically that has me sort of um
concerned about anticipating that's
going to spill over into Bitcoin in the
context of this kind of store value
discussion is the fact that we have a
having next Spring right I want to say
in April or May of 2024 and obviously
having to tend to be this you know very
very bullish event uh for Bitcoin and at
least that's what I thought initially in
my my speculation so I'm sitting here
thinking is Bitcoin even going to go
down in this phase two credit cycle
downturn let's say the Spy gets to you
know down 20 from here it'd be like 3200
or something does Bitcoin go to 17.5
again or is Bitcoin stay where it is or
even appreciate because that'll be very
close to that you know Springtime having
so I did a little work um you know this
morning kind of trying to identify okay
is there a history of volatility in
Bitcoin and heading into the havings OR
is the kind of the having the Catalyst
for the kind of record appreciation on
the other side of that and the you know
the results of the the study that I did
suggests that there's tends to be a lot
of volatility uh in the year into
Bitcoin um you know I can just read
these off you know sorry to not have
these off top of my head I'm usually
better than this but you know so into
the November 2012 Bitcoin having we saw
a minus 39 percent uh Max drawdown in
February of 20 2012 and so I'm looking
at the year prior to the havings
um and then we have saw minus 27
drawdown in August of 2012. in the July
16 having we saw a minus 30 drawdown on
August 15. we saw minus 25 drawdown in
November 15. we saw a minus 20 drawdown
to February 16 and we saw another minus
20 drawdown in June of 16 and then
lastly into the May of 2020 having we
saw a minus 48 drawdown into December 19
and then another minus 53 drawdown kind
of during covet in March of 2020. so
that's a lot of crashes man in the year
leading up to the having and so I just
want to put that out there and say Hey
look I know this is going to be a very
positive event I think if we're having
this conversation 18 months from now or
20 months from now at the end of 2024
bitcoin's probably at 200 000 if not
higher and I definitely would fully uh
buy into that view it's just the path to
getting there if you're trying to build
a big position to take advantage of that
is likely to be very volatile at least
that's what history suggests so
basically the idea would be yes when the
having occurs within 18 months or so of
that having you have these kind of
record price appreciation
um but in the year before the 12 months
prior there are these kind of big 20 to
40 50 drawdowns in price and so again
history could serve as a guide maybe
it's not perfect but it would tell us
that when you see those drawdowns then
those historically have been great
buying opportunities versus uh you know
waiting till the having or anything like
that yeah the key take the key takeaway
I'm trying to make is we know not we
don't know but we assume Bitcoin is
probably going to be very much higher in
price by in 20 months the problem is if
you're buying it today at thirty
thousand you need to be aware that hey
there's a here a long time series
history of these material drawdowns very
significant drawdowns you know Capital
destroying drawdowns into that event and
we also have this phase two credit cycle
downturn that is completely separate and
apart from anything that's going on in
the cryptocurrency ecosystem so as a
risk manager and that's kind of what our
clients you know kind of task us to do
with 42 macro the number one thing we're
trying to preach right now is patience
and prudence we're not trying to get
people to run out and short Bitcoin or
short the stock market what we're trying
to do is to have them understand hey
look there's going to be a better buying
opportunity ahead of us probably
sometime in the next call at two to
three quarters and take advantage of
that buying opportunity but between now
and then the goal was not to get rich
quick it's to get rich smart over a
longer period of time
I don't know if I agree with 20 months
but 24 months which basically would give
you one year till the having
um you know give or take so maybe
actually even longer than that uh and
then 18 months because like one of the
things that's interesting to me right is
like you get the price appreciation we
go back uh May of 2020 we get the having
and it took a couple of months maybe
till like August September and then you
started to see okay here we go right and
we went from 10K to 30k very quickly
yeah and I remember from 30 to 60
happened from I think literally Bitcoin
hit 31 000 on December 31st like it was
going up a thousand dollars a day and it
was like 27 000 on December 27 28 000 on
December 28th right I remember that very
well it was crazy right it was crazy and
so it went from 30 31 000 to 64 000 by
March and so in literally 90 days it
doubled in Price Right which is this
incredible run now it had a huge
drawdown 50 but it kind of just returned
right back to where it had been in
December right which was still 300
higher than where it had been at the
having point maybe a little bit more I
think it's like 8 500 or so when it hit
the having
and if that had been the whole thing
it'd be like wow we went from you know 8
500 to 64 000 that is this you know
really crazy uh kind of uh appreciation
but that drawdown happened to coincide
with uh China kicking out a bunch of the
miners and and uh more fifty percent of
the hash rate going on summer of 21 and
all summer long it basically was just
flat kind of hanging around thirty
thousand dollars and then when we got
into Q3 all of a sudden here we go again
and obviously at Peak at 69 000 back in
November of 21. and so when you look at
that what I always wonder is like how
much of the quote unquote you know price
appreciation happened really between
like September of 20 and March of 21 and
that was driven by the having versus if
it had the full 18 months like you
actually get a little bit of a higher
price but if that uh hash rate getting
kicked out of China doesn't happen would
it have gone higher like what would have
been different we'll never know but like
to me that is like one of the more under
discussed things is just like you
basically had this price appreciation
that was occurring kind of right on
schedule yeah then you get this external
shock from China making this decision 50
of the hash rate leaves right it's a
pretty big deal
but yet you still even got another
all-time high before the end of the year
totally I mean it's kind of crazy to
think about now yeah no I mean that was
that was a very wonderful time for me uh
you know I bought my first Bitcoin in
October of uh 2020. that was good that
was a good run a very good run
um yeah I think I know I mean you and I
we're on your program back then saying I
think bitcoin's going 100 000. yeah and
quite frankly I think it would have gone
to a hundred thousand had it not had
that you know you know exogenous
Catalyst in China
um you know so you know I think
this asset class is going to be you know
for a long period of time fraught with
sort of exogenous events whether it be
regulatory I mean mostly regulatory
obviously that was a regulatory event in
China you know they're not we're not the
only ones who can regulate by the way um
but this is you know I think the the
underlying message of the resiliency of
the asset class I don't necessarily mean
resiliency from the price appreciation
standpoint I mean resiliency from the
perspective of this thing ain't going
anywhere right like we had FTX and
Celsius and Luna and all this other
stuff happened in the last kind of 12
months and not one time that I see
anyone really question the longer term
viability of Bitcoin throughout this
entire process I mean we've seen people
blow up and left and right and put in
handcuffs left and right and it's it's
uh and to me so I'm very proud of the
asset class for that particular
perspective I just I think you know just
from a risk management perspective I
think you know there's a the path to
getting to this you know rainbow and
puppy dog type outcome is you know you
got to walk through the gotta walk
through the hood for a little bit what
are the institutions doing right now are
they mostly in cash are they looking at
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies are they in
equities uh oil like where are they kind
of tactically looking so that's a
phenomenal question so I'll bucket this
into into different categories of
institution investors they're sort of
your long only kind of you know you know
just you know longer term you know 12 to
18 month time Horizon on any holding
style investors
um those are your kind of large mutual
funds Pension funds and then you have
your sort of you know kind of hedge fund
oriented strategies you know these folks
tend to you know they kind of generally
need to be making money on a
month-to-month basis at the bare minimum
not having you know drawdowns in excess
of three to five percent you know
particularly these large multi-managed
Market neutral players the the latter
category these these Market neutral pod
shop type hedge fund Vehicles you know
to a man woman and child that everyone I
talk to and we have you know many
clients across the space they are all
trading as with a higher frequency than
they ever have in their entire career
like the the short-termism in that in
that community of investors has never
been more like ferocious and I think
that's part of like what you know ignore
Bitcoin for a second just look at the
chart of the S P 500 you know since May
of 2020 of last year it's going to
almost be a year we've been bouncing
around more or less between let's call
it 20 40 200 and 3800 you know we went
to 4300 in August and then we went to
like 3 500 in October but for the most
part we've been flat you pull up a
year-long chart of the s p it basically
hasn't gone anywhere but what it has
done it's been very violent you know
we've seen like a 10 rally then a 15
drawdown then a 20 rally then a 10
percent these are like annual returns so
we've had like five or six years worth
of returns to carve out if you're a good
Trader if you're a good active manager
to take advantage of so that Community
investors is extremely kind of narrowly
focused on you know kind of what's
really happening right in the here and
now and that concerns me from a
medium-term perspective because they're
PR their foresight on you know the phase
two credit cycle downturn some of these
longer term like kind of uh macro cycle
risks that I think you know we're likely
to start the rear the ugly head and
towards the back end of the year I just
don't think you're gonna have enough
investors focus on that which to allow
you to have kind of a market crash Style
Style outcome when you're talking about
the long only institutional money
managers everyone is positioned for down
dollar you know short the dollar and
every derivative trade of shorting the
dollar whether it be improving Global
growth whether it be Emerging Market
outperformance over U.S equities whether
it be Commodities over you know um hard
assets you know commodity to our
physical assets over digital assets you
know we've seen a little bit of a
crowding back into the tech space but
probably by and large you know those
investors and I've been having these
same conversations really for the past
kind of four or five months which is you
know how do I take advantage of down
dollar up Global growth without actually
just being long China given all the
Regulatory and geopolitical concerns
that are emanating out of that economy
so there's a lot of consensus across you
know kind of what I would consider
traditional Wall Street right now uh
whether it be just like knife fighting
for you know basis points on a daily
weekly basis or whether it be just you
know short the dollar both of those
things I think could be proven very
wrong you get to kind of one to two
quarters from now maybe not one quarter
now but certainly I think by the end of
Q3 this concept of down dollar you know
everything up Global growth I think will
fall by the wayside at least that's what
our models are suggesting and then the
concept of I don't really have to worry
about medium-term risk you know being in
the right exposures from a medium-term
perspective on the in the kind of the
shorter term pot shop exposures our head
managers that to me is a big worry for
me because again when you get into the
back half of the Year everyone's going
to start to recognize the deterioration
of the labor cycle you know kind of okay
we actually are might be heading into
recession but they can't all get out of
the same pipes at the same time you
can't all go by uh Procter Gamble at
once and sell everything else you own
because this is how markets crash
markets are very uh they've been very
illiquid for a few years now
when you look at
the current market situation we are
headed into uh next year a presidential
election we know that the FED uh they
are not an elected official they are
appointed does the president matter
we hear a lot of debate
Trump tax cuts or Biden this and and
sometimes it's tax positive things tax
negative things both sides the aisle
like there's all these debates
does the president matter increasingly
so but not at all on an absolute basis
on a relative basis they're certainly
gaining share uh you can this really
goes back to the Obama Administration
obviously Trump you know kicked it into
steroids but this concept of executive
orders and mostly because we've seen so
much gridlock in Congress that you can't
really get anything done that's from a
lasting budgetary perspective so
executive orders have been kind of the
way we've enacted policy here in the U.S
for for quite a long time now for over a
decade now and so we're seeing by the
invited with the most recent executive
order you know Banning investment to
Chinese Industries you know high-tech
Industries as well I think we're going
to continue to see more of that in the
context of this you know hyper
gridlocked you know DC economy I mean we
have a potential U.S sovereign debt uh
default on our hands in a few months and
neither side is willing to negotiate or
at least you know Democrats are
unwilling to negotiate and the freedom
caucus is unwilling to negotiate unless
they get what they want which is clearly
not a negotiation and so to me I think
you know the president does the
president matter yes do they really
matter in terms of asset markets
probably probably not you know if you
you know in terms of ranking this
clearly the FED is is sacrosanct two
investments in the U.S economy given you
know the control they don't control but
they materially contribute to the Ebbs
and flows of the liquidity cycle
um obviously Congress would be number
two in the context of them being the
institution that determines the budget
the other ones that determine the size
of the budget deficit the timing of
payments to them this all the stuff you
know where the money is getting
allocated in the economy the
distribution or lack thereof and the
economy and so I think you know those
two institutions and for a long time
they're they're going to matter a lot
more than the president but the
president matters as much as it has in
my career as much as it has today or
today it matters as much as it has ever
in my career yeah that's crazy where can
we send people to find you on the
internet oh appreciate you man always a
pleasure to come uh come top it up with
me I love the office really proud of you
guys uh so come check us out 42 macro uh
you know we do as as you can clearly
tell uh we do institutional uh research
for every investor that's that's our
model 42 macro.com and we're on Twitter
I'm on Twitter at 42 macro weather we
have a private Twitter account 42 macro
aware for our for our subscribers
awesome I learn every single time
appreciate macro.com everyone go check
it out we'll do it again always a
pleasure man thank you